a private equity started off as a
solution to some challenges that
American companies had back in the mid
70s and the challenge that a lot of
companies had was that the management of
those companies thought of themselves
separately from how the owners of
companies might think they got paid
whether the company did well or didn't
do well they didn't have skin in the
game also a problem in a lot of
companies was the fact that they thought
short-term and not long-term they
thought quarter-to-quarter and because
they depended for their capital on
public markets what their stock traded
at each quarter was critically important
what private equity does is it tries to
deal with those and some other problems
too first when we buy a company the
management of that company and the board
of that company are paid like we are the
owners of that company we're paid on
whether it grows over the long term not
the short term so if you're the CEO
you're not going to be jetting around
the country on a company plane
regardless of whether the company's
doing well because that's your money
that you're spending and that you're not
being efficient with respect to and
that's really important so one you deal
with they were some might call the
agency problem you make company owners
think like company managers excuse me
think like owners not simply like agents
the second thing that we are able to do
we own companies for an average of seven
years if your horizon is how do you a
girl company over seven years not simply
what's the stock trading each day then
you're a lot more likely to focus on
things like how do I grow into a new
market even if that's going to cost us
something over the initial period you
think about how do you expand for
example capex how do you make companies
think more long-term than short-term the
second area that's important from
private equity is if you think about it
the people that invest in private equity
we look at our recent funds there are 9
million retirees a lot of them were once
teachers they were once firemen or
police there are folks that have worked
very hard all their lives and because
their state pension fund chose to invest
in private equity their returns are
better and their retirement is more
secure and what that means is
is that the communities in which they
operate which otherwise might have to
divert resources away from public
services or education to pay for the
retirement they don't have to